please to have here on my set one of my
favorite people I think I did more NFL
total accesses with this man than
anybody else and the one year that I was
honored to be the emcee of the Pro
Football Hall of Fame was a year that he
went in and it is an honor as I have a
good friend Rod Woodson back here on the
show how good seeing you thanks for
coming straight from the airport my
pleasure
you don't take your shoes off on a plane
to you I do not okay well cross-country
yes what do you mean I'll crawl if I'm
going across the United States you will
take your shoes off on a plane taking my
shoe I might take my socks off too now
rod hold on I need to be comfortable
I understand this lien it's not your is
it a flying living room you know what
I'm saying my god I'm there too yeah I'm
there too my feet smell good rich are
you really roses you never struck me as
a my feet don't stink type of guy you
know I always thought that you you're
humble
well I just wanted to make sure if you
got take the socks off and some people
feet do smell like like old corn chowder
or something like non roses yeah okay so
good to see you man it is I would love
for you to start with what you said on
the Callaway corner during the TV only
segment where you're putting about
number 26 of the New York Football
Giants you know a lot of people
criticize the Giants for taking Berkeley
so high up because they're they're
talking about Eli being on his last leg
and you know replacing him but you have
to take the best player there and he is
by far he was the best player in the
draft he is so special I mean he reminds
me of a combination of a Barry Sanders
Chuck Forman a Earl Campbell all
combined into one and a common used
Emmitt Smith as a comparison because of
the number of times people miss on the
first attempt to tackle him yeah and
it's just his his runs that he makes the
first touchdown run he had this year
where he scampered through the middle
john-john it to the right it was like a
68 yard or something that nature
he made three people miss and then he
outran everybody to with their angles
when he got to the sidelines that is not
normal and you didn't talk about rookies
this way I normally
don't but that's not normal you see
flashes of greatness but this kid is
really special was the toughest running
back you ever had a tackle
oh I had the tackle yes sir Kevin Mack
he was the hardest one that like
physically to brag though bring down all
right now the best running back ever
played against is Barry Sanders he is
when he was the one guy that when you
played against him we had rules for our
defensive ends they couldn't get too
high up toward the quarterback because
he had you gave him a running Lane he
was gonna take it and then another rules
that we didn't fold early what do you
mean meaning is so if I'm on the right
side he's going to the left we stayed
because he was gonna come back and most
running backs don't do that they stay on
this front side right but you know Barry
would be one of those guys can cut and
see had great vision had strong legs was
faster than what people thought and this
kid is faster than what people think he
is too
well Ron I mean that then the number of
people who have said that they made a
mistake choosing Barkley because Eli is
on its last legs as you point as you as
you said the number of people who said
that maybe have doubled or tripled
overnight based on what we saw last
night do you think it's this is a wrap
for Eli Manning yeah I never thought a
Eli was an elite quarterback I think he
always played well the year they won a
Super Bowl he had some solid games
leading up to the point the last year
their defensive front was just a pretty
good front that got after the opposing
quarterbacks I never thought he was you
know that franchise quarterback even
though he's been there a long time to me
franchise quarterbacks transcends your
team the Aaron Rodgers the Tom Brady's
the drew breezes even the Philip Rivers
I mean those type of guys they stay
there but they make your team better
just because they're on your team those
are franchise quarterbacks to me those
are rare players we can all say that
these are all these guys every team has
a franchise quarterback cuz he's been
there 10 years I think to me I think
that's just like selling a dream to a
fan base that's awake I just think that
you have to be very careful with that
I like to me my standard is higher and
when I say I have a franchise
quarterback it's gonna be one of those
type of guys
and Eli's not that guy I don't think
Elias do you think he is regardless of
whether he was or not or is or not is he
on his last legs do you see a
quarterback that is done yes I think
he's I think well first of all it
started judging what the lack of
protection that he does have that is
tough as tough on a young quarterback
it's definitely tough on a veteran
quarterback that is definitely tough on
a quarterback that we know he's gonna be
seven yards deep behind the center in a
guard he's not moving he's not going
anywhere he's not getting out of the
pocket he can't get out of the pocket
he's never been that type of quarterback
and now you have less protection for him
and it's tougher for him but I just
think that this is his last year so but
he's in Brady UConn that you know where
he's gonna be in the pocket - yeah but
he's different
he's that guy that he's seen everything
he's gonna be seven yards behind the
quarterback but he he can anticipate he
knows who he wants to who he wants to
challenge
he knows the defense before it's even
ran but Elon does - don't you think you
know what neck up on Eli Manning has
never been in there the question I don't
think he sees it like tom-toms different
Aaron Rodgers different Drew Brees is
different than all those other
quarterbacks Phillip Rivers is different
than all the other quarterbacks they can
still like Phillip Rivers he can't run
from me to you
in 20 seconds man he can throw the
football and that's what Dan Marino was
the same way Danny couldn't run for me -
you - but Danny could throw the football
and those type of quarterbacks to me are
the hardest ones to face because you
can't disguise against him and then if
you give him any little room any little
notice of what you're doing as a defense
they pick you apart I gotta be careful
Rod Woodson cuz Eli Manning maybe in
that bus gallery with you one day
what bus I don't own a bus bust Gallow
bust gallery I don't vote okay I don't
know see but if you did would you put
him in the bust gallery with you I would
say the Hall of Fame to me is the
greatest of the greatest to ever play in
the National Football
there's only 300 some of my guys in the
league troop that's you know players and
contributors and when you look at all
the quarterbacks that are in does he
strike you as one of being one of those
guys to me I say no and I you know
watching for a long time played against
his brother coached against him last
year or no excuse me not he wasn't there
it was a year that was the game that he
got been that's the Geno Smith down the
Geno Smith game you know so didn't get
the coach against him but weren't
preparing for that game I'm like he's a
looker and what I mean by that is
quarterbacks there's certain
quarterbacks that can look you off like
Drew Brees on his the touchdown breaking
pass that he had yes game he was dropped
back and he and and Sean Payton is
really good as teaching his quarterbacks
how to pump away but they know that db's
Reid shoulders of the quarterback and he
to hand pump yeah you know that Jeff /
yeah yeah yeah which brought the
defender up which gave him a bigger gap
throw on the back side of the on the
sideline and he took that that pass to
me I just don't see Eli being that type
of guy what about Phillip would you put
him in the bus room that's a that's a
tough one
that's a real tough one because I love
the way he plays I love how he can throw
the football I mean he'll sling a
sidearm you know and it gets there and
he's never had a bunch of great talented
receivers he did have the runt you know
he had LT he had you know you did have
the tight in gates in gates he will be
in the Buster absolutely right gates
will be right and I think Phillip will
definitely I think he would get in so I
could I put him at high praise cuz you
know I just know that he's not real he's
not real athletic but the guy's a great
competitor
and he's a great throw derful and what
about the last member of the 2004 class
still around and Big Ben do you think
he's a Hall of Famer Ron I I like Ben
I do and I think he's in that category I
don't know if he transcends the teams I
don't know if he went to Green Bay Green
Bay has to be Green Bay I'm not sure
that I know if Aaron Rodgers still went
to Pittsburgh Pittsburgh was still
probably might be better because he's
more he's a little bit more mobile
but I've always liked Ben I think Ben is
one of those quarterbacks that you know
he's taken the team to another level
he's had some great players around him
over the years you know so he'll be
another one that's that's argued about
getting in and it's a quarterback driven
league the rules have changed over the
years so I think we have to pump the
brakes on two things cuz we see this
like this explosion on offense this we
do where so many points and yards are
just given on a daily basis and it how
terrible the tackling is gone in the
National Football League is just crazy
but with that being said I think we have
to pump our brakes because we're these
receivers are just catching the ball so
ease it there they overly protect it the
quarterbacks over we protect it in the
pocket out of the pocket they can throw
what they can do whatever they want to
you can't land on them you don't know
how to tackle them and I think no he's
allergic to that you know to me I think
we have to pump our brakes with some of
these younger guys they say we can't
crown them so fast they got to do it or
the longer period of time I got three
minutes left with you here Rod Woodson
all eyes peeled for love Bell right now
because he said he would come back
around week eight maybe he wants to
collect some checks he comes in now
they're not gonna play him this week and
then they gotta buy so he can get a
couple one point six millon his pocket
if he shows up today or tomorrow if he
does what happens in that locker room d4
he's not gonna show up now I think if he
does show up it will be after the bye
okay not during the buy I think it'll be
after the buy I would love to see him
come in I think he's a competitor and
since James Harris put it out there
already saying if he's gonna might come
in and you know he should get like a you
know a hamstring pool mm-hmm I don't
think he can do that I think he I think
he's a competitor I think he's gonna
come in I think he's gonna help that
football team win some games
they're not a September team they've
always played ban in September for some
reason hmm you know under especially
under Tomlin but October they play a
little bit better I think they're gonna
win this game when they go on the road
against Cincinnati they always play well
in Cincinnati so III think they're gonna
get back on the right track and it's Tom
on the right guy for the job Stella do
you think I love my you know Steeler
Nation every every every year seems to
wane a little bit on there's some of the
rules that he has on the defensive side
and that I have questions about what do
you mean well I mean just you know when
you go back and watch a Kansas City game
they're playing single high defense on
the 10-yard line
a true cover three and they're not
touching the slot players meaning our
curl flat players not standing there
rerouting the number two player to get
the number one player who's a two to one
read corner opportunity to get back
there it's like some of those things
like you wouldn't a saw with a Dick
LeBeau defense but it's not his so the
defense is different they're putting a
lot more Tampa to to more two-man than
normal but I think it's going to all
come together they got some good young
talent and if the orphans can carry them
till they find their legs then I think
that would happen well I got to send you
up the 405 to the NFL Network you're on
Total Access tonight without me that's
right I'm gonna start crying when I get
up there am I your quarterback you're
your might do my guy real quick just in
the 40 seconds we have left here my
favorite story is when you thought that
Sean Alexander needed more MVP love but
he thought the Seattle Seahawk front
office wasn't they haunting the table
for him they weren't all that out and
and we got a call from the other side
saying hey the Seahawks have been very
good giving us these players rods rods
got to pull back on that later on in the
show and you're like pologize well you
you found that information like rod can
you say something later on in the show
just to soften what you said and you're
like what like they told you you're like
okay they come on camera rod you want to
say something to the Seattle Seahawks
and he goes sorry
like that was it I'm sowwy like a baby
just like a little kid apologizes for
telling the truth
he spits the truth tonight NFL Total
Access at 7:00 Eastern Time
thanks for coming here and keeping your
shoes on for the segment right I
appreciate it's comfortable here come on
back Robinson the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience